John Carpenter's 1988 opus They Live is a
scathing indictment of capitalism and the
culture of greed masquerading as a B movie
about invading aliens.
It stars professional wrestler "Rowdy" Roddy
Piper as a homeless laborer whose world is
turned upside down when he finds a box of
special sunglasses that allow the wearer to
see the truth about subliminal messaging forcing
humanity to OBEY.
It’s one of Carpenter's greatest films,
but grab a pair of Hoffman lenses for yourself
to see the truth that even hardcore fans may
not know about They Live.
H.P.
Lovecraft, Ray Nelson, and Richard Armitage
Sharp-eyed viewers may have noticed that the
screenplay is credited to Frank Armitage,
which happens to be the same name as Keith
David's character.
This, of course, is a pseudonym.
Carpenter wrote the screenplay but felt it
was enough of a collaborative effort with
his future wife Sandy King, and Roddy Piper
as well, that he didn’t take sole credit.
Instead, he lifted the name “Armitage”
from The Dunwich Horror, a classic story by
H.P.
Lovecraft, whose work often involved characters
being driven mad by discovering hidden truths.
Lovecraft wasn’t the direct inspiration
for They Live, though.
Instead, Carpenter drew from another short
story: Ray Nelson's "Eight O'Clock in the
Morning."
Published in 1963, and turned into a comic
book in 1986, it features a character named
Nada who awakens to the fact that the world
is secretly being run by snake-like aliens
who control humanity's thoughts and actions.
While many of the story's elements would later
make it to the screen, Carpenter wisely added
a few tweaks to the plot and changed a few
elements to make it more believable.
Or at least as believable as a story about
magic sunglasses that let you see aliens can
be.
“I’m givin’ you a choice, either put
on these glasses, or start eating that trash
can.”
The Man With No Name
Like the lead character of Nelson’s short
story, Roddy Piper’s character is called
“Nada” because he is meant to be a blank
slate everyman.
He is given very little backstory and is never
referred to by his name in the film even once,
with “Nada” only appearing in the credits.
In the years since, though, Carpenter has
let it slip that the character's first name
is John, and that he indeed has an extensive
backstory, even if the filmmaker himself doesn't
know what it is.
“I’ve had a rough couple of days.”
In an interview, Carpenter revealed that only
one man knew Nada’s full origin story: Roddy
Piper.
Before filming, Carpenter asked Piper to come
up with a backstory on his own, and further
told him to never share what it was with the
director, to lend his character more authenticity.
True to his word, Piper never went on the
record before his untimely death in 2015,
meaning that Nada will always be what Carpenter
intended: a mystery to everyone, even the
man who wrote and directed the movie.
The most brutal brawl in cinema history
At nearly six minutes long, the iconic alleyway
fight between Nada and Frank is one of the
most celebrated brawls in film history.
It's been endlessly referenced, quoted and
parodied, and it’s inevitably brought up
as a point of comparison every time new contender
for the "best fight scene of all time" emerges.
“...Oh man, I’m sorry!”
With the idea of creating a fight scene that
would be completely unique in films, Carpenter
turned to stunt coordinator Jeff Imada, whose
work can be seen in action movies like Lethal
Weapon, The Bourne Conspiracy, and Furious
7, and to Piper, drawing on his experience
as a professional wrestler.
The result speaks for itself, but David complimented
Piper on helping to make the film more realistic,
while Piper’s assessment of David makes
it clear that he’s no slouch either.
"This guy hits like a mule!”
He's all out of bubblegum
Soon after Nada's unpleasant discovery about
the world around him, he has a scuffle with
a pair of cops and manages to get away with
one of their shotguns by ducking into a building,
which turns out to be a bank.
As the patrons react to Nada with his shades
and shotgun, he utters one of the all-time
classic badass lines in cinema history:
“I have come here to chew bubblegum and
kick ass … and I'm all out of bubblegum.”
The line has been embedded in pop culture
ever since, but it wasn't Carpenter's creation,
it came directly from Piper.
According to Carpenter, Piper carried a book
full of one-liners that he’d use in his
wrestling promos, and while he was writing
the script, Carpenter lifted the best one
for the scene.
It’s just a shame he never got to use that
one on Hulk Hogan.
Sticking it to Reagan
Carpenter's choice to make his heroes down-on-their-luck
homeless men up against alien invaders who
all seem to be rich yuppies (and, more frighteningly,
politicians) underlines the film's ultimate
message, which should be even clearer today
than it was 30 years ago.
Carpenter has gone as far as calling it a
documentary about the exploitation of the
poor by the upper class and an indictment
of the rampant economic inequality that makes
it possible, and even filmed the opening in
an actual homeless settlement, paying the
residents as extras.
If Carpenter intended They Live to be a ballistic
missile lobbed at '80s materialism and excess,
he's never been shy about who he saw as the
ultimate symbol of that excess: President
Ronald Reagan.
Speaking with Starlog around the time of the
film's release, Carpenter was clear on this
point, calling the president and his cabinet
"a bunch of crooks.”
In the years since, Carpenter has been happy
to elaborate on his contempt for Reagan whenever
given the opportunity.
In an interview with the Los Angeles Times
in 2013, Carpenter said that he’d “decided
I had to make a statement … and that's They
Live,” citing the literal and figurative
way that it “was giving the finger to Reagan
when nobody else would."